(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] This is a Chinese alligator.
Native to eastern China, it is so rare
that there are only 130 left in the wild.
Known as the Yangtze alligator,
it is one of the smallest
crocodilians in the world.
Their stocky body is covered
in hard scales on the back
and its blunt teeth are perfect
for crushing shelled animals,
like clams and snails.
Their menu also includes fish, insects,
birds, and the occasional small mammal.
They stay in subtropical areas
with fresh water sources,
like lakes, ponds, marshes, and streams.
Sadly, these habitats are disappearing,
often to make room for agriculture.
This and poaching are the biggest threats
to the survival of the species.
Luckily, they do well in captivity,
as they have been successfully bred
in wildlife refuges and zoos.
This is the Chinese alligator.